euro i am bret baer breaking tonight
what could be a major breach of national
security and international relations
at the hands of former secretary of
state current climate adviser
john kerry it involves what kerry told
an iranian official
about israel's involvement in attacks on
the islamic republic's
armed forces inside syria democrats are
dismissing any controversy republicans
as you can imagine
are not state department correspondent
rich edson has tonight's top story
from the state department good evening
rich good evening brett and republicans
say they want an investigation some are
even calling for former secretary
kerry's resignation
all in response to claims from iran's
foreign minister
in a conversation leaked right in the
middle of negotiations
over the iran nuclear deal a leaked
discussion with iran's chief diplomat
reveals just how powerful iran's
military is
and what john kerry was saying about one
of america's closest allies
iranian foreign minister javad zarif
claims quote it was former u.s foreign
secretary john kerry
who told me israel had launched more
than 200 attacks
on iranian forces in syria the israeli
government had no comment on zarif's
claim
the state department pointed to reports
where the israeli government
publicly confirmed the strikes i can't
speak to the accuracy of it can't speak
to any motives
that may be behind its dissemination
i would just make the broad point that
if you go back and look at press
reporting from the time
this certainly was not secret it's
unclear if zarif mentions when kerry may
have told him this information
congressman michael mccall the top
republican on the house foreign affairs
committee says quote
if true this reporting is incredibly
concerning
relaying sensitive information to the
number one state sponsor of terrorism is
just
unfathomable our security partnership in
the region
is is based on the unshakable trust
between
the united states and israel we need to
maintain that and
sharing sensitive information like this
if it happened
could really strike at the heart of the
bilateral relationship the three-hour
taped conversation between zarif and an
iranian journalist
leaked to the london-based news outlet
iran international
and the new york times fox news has not
independently verified the recorded
discussion
it comes as the u.s and iran resumed
tense negotiations to try to resuscitate
the 2015 nuclear agreement
iran's foreign ministry says officials
there are investigating the leak
absolutely illegal matter has happened
in the conversation zarif gripes about
kudz force commander qasim sulaimani for
undermining his diplomatic efforts
even traveling to moscow to work with
the russians to sabotage the 2015
nuclear deal
a u.s airstrike last year killed
suleimani zarif called it a major blow
mike pompeo was secretary of state then
he tweeted quote
our administration's exquisite strike on
qasim soleimani had a massive
impact on iran and the middle east you
don't have to take my word for it
ask javad zarif president biden still
thinks it was a mistake
state department says this week the u.s
will begin a third round of negotiations
to try to revive that 2015 nuclear
agreement
a senior state department official says
there has been progress
though there needs to be much more to
reach a deal
brett you know rich there are many
statements coming from republicans in
various positions up on capitol hill
about this
the state department's saying it's no
big deal because those attacks were in
the press
but it's one thing to read it in the new
york times and another thing to get a
call from the former secretary of state
telling you
that's in fact what's happening and you
also don't know what the timing of this
all is brett the state department really
not wanting to comment on any of this
just other than that line that you heard
from the spokesperson there but it's
still unclear
when the former secretary of state if he
did indeed tell the iranians this when
he did tell them
that okay we'll continue to look at it
rich thank you